brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on playstation 4 and xbox one
November 29th hey guys my name is Jess
and for us non-americans it's just the
24th of November but for you Americans
Happy Thanksgiving be sure to eat lots
game lots and maybe check out what's
happening in gaming news for next 3 to 4
minutes first up by our said that Mass
Effect Andromeda is the biggest game
they've ever made by our producer Mike
gamble told Game Informer this is the
biggest we've ever gone in terms of the
number of pieces of content there are
combat related encounters puzzle related
encounters narrative related encounters
and a lot of things will happen that add
more depth to the critical path by where
said they're aiming to make each and
every area memorable Andromeda will also
include loyalty missions for its
supporting characters much like in Mass
Effect 2 as well as conflict between
enemy factions and the ability to scan
entire planets if you're still hungry
for more overwatch events it sounds like
you'll be in for a treat to come
Christmas lizard haven't officially
announced their plans for a holiday
overwatch event but data miners have
uncovered a christmas medley of
overwatch of music which you can listen
to right now
the data miners also uncovered new voice
lines mainly involving newcomer sombra
earlier this week Blizzard released an
updated and improved version of symetra
on the overwatch public test realm on PC
another feature is in PT are called stay
as a team which lets you group with
random and choose to stay with them
after a game is completed finally
Ubisoft is still in hot water trying to
fend off a hostile takeover from vivendi
Ubisoft vice president of live
operations and blundell told pc games
and if you separate us from our
independence if you take away the way we
like taking risks and inventing new
stuff well it's not going to be the same
Ubisoft I know what made us so
successful for 30 years is being super
independent being very autonomous
blondell added that there's a concern a
takeover would prevent the publisher
from taking risks on games like they did
with the crew and valiant hearts Ubisoft
has always been a family run company and
is in the process of trying to safeguard
its independence by buying back more
shares Ubisoft CEO of gamma has said
that he would not continue a CEO under a
vivendi own to Ubisoft while you be are
struggling with business drama there
still came to get you some free stuff
for the holidays starting today you B's
giving away a bunch of games and other
cool things for 30 days to celebrate its
30th birthday Roman classic is free on
mobile today and you can expect free
digital assets as well as discounts on
games and other things over the coming
weeks head to our story on site for
details on how to claim your goodies
that is everything I've got for you
today do head to gamespot for our watch
dogs to review and be sure to pop by
again tomorrow for the biggest stories
of the whole week I'll see you then